[Music]
[Applause]
if you don't know this is a segment
where viewers try to find mistakes on
our show okay so far hundreds of
challengers not one winner we make
mistakes well tonight a fan with the
screen name animation B thinks he caught
a mistake he says it happened during one
of my regular comedy segments Conan's
video blog
hello Conan you didn't error on your
show in your video blog segment the one
where you Batman if I had a bunch of
famous people you had a picture of Buzz
Aldrin and you put a Batman mask over
his space helmet famous images where
everyone is madman Neil Armstrong on the
moon Batman you said that it was Neil
Armstrong the first men on the moon when
in fact the picture was a Buzz Aldrin so
that's an error sorry
well first of all pal good luck with
your plans sailboat invasion of coastal
Russia
[Applause]
hope that works out for you but now the
bad news sorry
animation B you are dead wrong that is
Neil Armstrong in that photo
not Buzz Aldrin now you doubt me well
here's a message from a man who should
know the second man on the moon
Colonel Buzz Aldrin thank you hey
animation B you're wrong and I'm gonna
prove it let's look at the photo you say
that's me okay check out the name badge
it says Aldrin looks like you're right
but notice the helmet can you see my
face no this is a secret I've been
keeping for almost half a century on
July 20th 1969 Neil Armstrong and I
pulled off humanity's first
extraterrestrial prank just before we
left the lunar module we switched
spacesuits you want proof push in on a
reflection in the helmet
you can tell it's good this also means
that i buzz aldrin was actually the
first man to walk on the moon I can
prove that as well show the footage with
state-of-the-art digitally enhanced
audio Thank You Conan for letting me set
the record straight and as for you
animation me school of punk
[Applause]
[Music]
all right so the challenge still stands
if you think you've spotted an era na na
show reported a team koco.com / aha I
found an error we will sort it out right
here on the air let's see if you've got
what it takes to make junk meat out of
the maestro